[Music]
good afternoon everyone
welcome to the kubernetes engine
enterprise-ready networking session
today I will talk to you about why
kubernetes engine is the choice of
platform for anybody's workloads so a
little bit of recap kubernetes engine
was generally when generally available
in 2015 and kubernetes was born in the
cloud it was always a very developer
friendly environment and also the choice
of platform for cloud native what does
that mean cloud native cares about a lot
of things like developer agility
automation and also having a great
experience enterprises they care about
all of that and a lot more today I will
mention how kubernetes engine has gone
through that journey of also becoming
the choice of platform for enterprise
workloads now let's talk about what does
it actually mean to be enterprise ready
so in front of you are the four pillars
of enterprise readiness comprising of
the first one being deployed deployment
simplicity deployment simplicity is
being able to control and manage and
scale all your cluster resources
seamlessly with enough control
fine-grained control typically an
enterprise would want to isolate their
critical network resources from your
non-critical ones but still have the
flexibility given to your project admins
to create and manage clusters and I'll
talk about how kubernetes engine helps
you get that the third being security
security is a very important pillar for
a lot of for all enterprises I will talk
how kubernetes engine ensures that all
your request paths whether it's within
your VPC whether it's to and from the
internet or connecting to other Google
services are secure and last but not the
least with ability of course it is very
important for enterprises to be able to
see what is
going on within their network and I'll
display how exactly kubernetes engine
helps you get that visibility which is
so crucial to your deployments and how
all these four pillars work together to
give a unified experience now I welcome
to stage Brad who's a lead system
architect from symphony to talk about
his journey with us thank you my job so
just to give you a little bit of an idea
of what we experienced and who we are
Symphony is secure messaging platform
secure collaboration platform really
aimed at very very secure 'uncle and
financial services industry primarily so
we spend a lot of our time talking to
some of the most sensitive security
sensitive enterprises there on the
planet so from a enterprise readiness
perspective we certainly even though we
ourselves are a start-up we experienced
that Enterprise readiness need very
succinctly the set of customers that we
deal with our cautious of public
internet they want the cloud native Nate
features that meant Joe mentioned the
ability to be agile the ability to be
more nimble and and less locally
expensive they were running a lot of
their workloads on-premise today but
they want to move them to the cloud for
all the same reasons that any of the
consumer facing applications have moved
to the cloud but they're cautious and
and and concerned about the security and
so functionally as we went through this
we started working very closely with the
gke team to become cloud native to bring
that cloud nativeness into these
enterprises from our perspective the
problem with the cloud nativeness was
primarily driven around getting the
traditional way of thinking about
networking solved in a way that we don't
have the internet as the problem which
is exactly the opposite of what the
cloud is of course because the cloud is
right on the internet everybody knows
the Internet's between it and the actual
work the actual users of the work so
functionally private clusters very
important
for us we worked very closely with
Manjit and her team to get private
clusters accelerated to the point where
we could set our to use them keeping all
the IP addressing in a private space on
the V PC none of it ever exposed out
into the public internet making the
enterprise very comfortable with the
fact that they understood where their
traffic patterns were flowing and they
didn't have problems likely to be
affected by even the things we've seen
in the in the news recently like BGP
routing attacks or other things where
public internet would have been a
problem so now they are enterprises our
largest customers they don't connect
even though they use either a direct
connect into the cloud or they use a VPN
connection that they trust very
succinctly communicating overly over
private IPs allowing for that secure
platform that we built to be deployed in
a cloud native way and our customers to
consume it so we really do believe that
this these features are really important
to making it happen in an enterprise
ready fashion and we hope that your
enterprises will start to adopt some of
these features as well with Google being
kind of leading the charge on kubernetes
and I think next Mahesh is going to come
up and speak a little bit more thank you
thanks a lot Rob that was pretty
interesting thanks for tying up how
kubernetes engine provides features as
that meets a requirement good morning
everyone my name is Mahesh Narayan I'm a
product manager in the cloud networking
team working on GK
well the Surya please
what we talked about you know the four
pillars deployment simplicity
fine-grained control security and
visibility but there's so many of us
when we try a new platform we find that
it misses or does not have certain key
fundamental features and our reaction is
what do you mean it doesn't work I can
do that today on my current platform
well our hope is during the course of
this discussion we will show it show to
you how kubernetes is kubernetes engine
is a great platform for
prize deployment and help avoid this
reaction from you we have a mixed crowd
so before we get into the different
aspects of what and enterprise readiness
means let's talk about certain building
blocks of kubernetes engine these
building blocks will be used to explain
other topics in this just in this
section so it will be useful over the
next 40 minutes as well we all know
about virtual private cloud this is the
building block of GCP GCP networking a
virtual private cloud in GCP provides a
global fully meshed and a private IP
network this is in fact the customer
slice customers networks lies in the GCP
network within a VPC we have certain
networks which provides regional
boundaries within a VPC and they they
they give a location connotation these
two are the fundamental building blocks
of GCP whether you are doing GC p gk e
or GCE or anything of that sort
kubernetes engine adds few more
networking elements to the mix let's
talk about those first among them is the
kubernetes engine cluster a cluster
consists of nodes pods and services a
cluster also has a clustered master
which is the brains behind controlling
the custard it provides the control
plane functionality to manage the
cluster a VPC can have multiple clusters
nodes are VM instances on which pods are
run the nodes provide compute networking
and storage resources to the different
pods depending upon the pods resource
constraints you can have nodes of
different sizes the node gets an IP and
its routable by default pods think of
them as tiny tasks specific processes
that are running on top of your nodes a
pod gets an auto an IP automatically and
is also routable by default a pod can
run one container or multiple containers
such as a docker container I mean there
are multiple containers running on top
of a hard
all of them are managed as a single
entity sharing the resources of the pod
services
if service is something that is
long-lived and provides a stable and a
fixed endpoints to represent all your
parts a part on the other hand is
ephemeral it can come and go because of
you know failures or scalability so pods
are ephemeral services are are
long-lived
and they provide an app services
basically provide an abstraction for all
your pods a good example for services is
a load balancer all this comes together
in a flat networking water flat
networking model where VP C is the
underlying glue that provides a fully
meshed network and in this fully meshed
network all the nodes can talk to each
other all the pods can talk to each
other and all the nodes and parts can
talk to each other by default the the
benefits of this model become more
obvious during the next few sections
deployment simplicity so you know one
size doesn't fit all and this is
especially true for Cuba Nettie's Engine
4 for enterprise networking that has
evolved over time so kubernetes engine
has an interesting challenge at hand for
deployment simply the deployment
simplicity it needs to ensure that it's
providing the best practices in
networking in enterprise networking
especially and at the same time
integrate well with a with an
enterprise's on film as well as cloud
presence so let's talk about what are
the different aspects within deployment
simplicity one is control
first and foremost customers do not like
surprises they want tight control over
all their resources one way kubernetes
engine delivers this is by having
distinct ranges for the different
resources so if you have if the
corporate has a policy man it's a policy
where they say the node should not talk
to each other but the pods should be
able to talk he talk to each other by
having distinct ranges for nodes pod and
services it makes it a more intuitive
model for you to apply such a policy you
know you can use a firewall policy to
block the nodes but allow and then the
departs by default are talking to each
other this is a much simpler model to
implement in your network control is
also exerted extended in the form of
provisioning flexibility when you are if
you haven't if you're an enterprise
customer who have who has a very
intricate deployment scheme you can
either let us decide the address manager
addresses for you these address ranges
for you or you also have the
user-defined option and the user-defined
option is very critical for again for
the customers who have a very intricate
scheme just as how you are define an IP
in a V PC and you map that to a region
through sub networks you can create
custom sub networks and map the node
pods and services in a particular region
this gives you very fine-grained control
this can this makes your cluster size
fungible and also saw the bin packing
problem so forgot to animate this so in
this example as you can see the you know
since these ranges are different the
nodes you can apply a firewall policy or
a security policy which stops the node
from talking to each other but pods pods
can talk to each other
centralized management as more customers
start deploying cube annuities engine we
have seen that one of the most often
asked questions from customer is around
address management for certain large
sized enterprises IP addresses even
private IP addresses is a precious
commodity they want to ensure that the
scheme that they land on for addressing
makes sense works for them as they scale
out in future so humanities engine
stalls is problem for the customer by by
understanding what is being used where
it is being used what is available and
what is the min/max size for the
different resources right the other
advantage of using other advantages
model is that we track the IP addresses
as you grow your cluster across your
cluster so with this tracking and check
we ensure that there is no address
pollution as you grow more resources in
the cluster or you grow even your
clusters you grow into multiple clusters
this tracking is done dynamically and at
runtime and it also ensures that not
only is your gke footprint not getting
address collision but even your GCP
footprint is not getting any address
collision so if you are building
something in on GK and you're also using
certain elements on GCP let's say
see or a load balancer internal load
balancer we ensure that there is no
collision across the across the two
integrated networking so when kubernetes
was introduced there were multiple
models to implement container IP
connectivity some implemented
encapsulated overlay networks you know
there was Network route programming for
directing the container traffic but in
both these models the the the container
route the networking was kind of bolted
on to the cluster to the cloud
infrastructure making it less agile and
you know coming up with the list of
features that were caveated
with the launch of VPC native clusters
clusters and the different resources are
now integrated within the Google cloud
infrastructure all the clusters and the
different resources again are
first-class citizens within a VP C now
what that means is features like shared
vp c vp c peering access to google
services all are available by default to
your GK application application is
running on kubernetes engine as an
example if you are running you know if
you're using cards and you were
accessing these services cloud storage
bit cloud bit table over a public IP
with VPC native knob you can now access
these services over the pods private IP
as well you know it's it's it's seamless
lastly hybrid support no kubernetes
engine deployment is complete without
providing support for hybrid networking
right we want to ensure that for easy
onboarding of kubernetes engine the
mechanisms that exist today to make
on-prem talk to cloud work seamlessly
for kubernetes engine as well so with
that in mind kubernetes engine clusters
are transparent to entre we have the
concept of cloud routers which
facilitates the communication between on
Prem and GK cluster seamlessly you can
use the existing VPN mechanism whether
cloud whether it is cloud VPN or
dedicated internet or partner
interconnect and connect from your
on-prem to the GK class so the
kubernetes clusters you can also have
very tight control over what gets to
talk to whom so if you want to ensure
that from one frame only certain
applications or pods are available
to communicate with again from the help
of cloud router and using routing you
can advertise specific subnets between
the on-prem and the cloud but that I'll
hand it over to Manju thank you thank
you so much Mahesh now I will talk about
security you all have a tough job
security is one of those things which is
never enough and we are gke really even
having both belts and suspenders and now
I will talk about how GAE tries to
ensure that your all your surface areas
of attacks are covered we have TKE
believe in a layered security model
where we cover every aspect and every
layer of your deployment that should be
secured broadly dividing it into config
time and runtime security where config
time consists of separation of
administrative control for Europe for
your deployments and runtime consists of
private deployments and network security
now separation of administrative control
what it enables you to do is typically
you would have an organization with an
infrastructure and a platform team which
would want to control your critical
network resources and still have your
app or your front-end teams be able to
create and manage their gke clusters and
run time security private deployments
enables you to get network segmentation
where your back-end services which
shouldn't be exposed on the Internet are
not and network security dives deeper a
layer deeper from private deployments
and drills down within your cluster to
enable you to control your inter-service
communication shared VPC I will pick up
the first one which was a separation of
administrative controls so share VPC
enables you to map your organizational
topology on to your critical network
resources and how does it actually allow
you to do that so Cooper Nellie solve
the problem of enabling
you to write your infrastructure less
code but we need to still reconcile your
operational security models with that
and what shared VPC does is it enables
your critical network resources such as
firewalls and other such resources to be
controlled by a handful of network and
security admins and your project or your
cluster admins still have the ability to
be able to create clusters within a
shared network and not have to deal with
things like network and security
critical resources developers should be
able to code test and deploy their
applications without having to deal with
questions of connectivity or firewalls
and shared VPC enables you to do that so
talking about what are the benefits that
shared VPC actually gives you first
thing that I've already mentioned is
separation of your security and your
other and your project admin roles so
typically in a deployment or an
organization you won't have your
infrastructure teams and your platform
teams controlling those network
resources and have your project teams or
your application teams being able to
create and deploy clusters in the shared
subnets without having the ability to
change those resources and that gives
you separation of roles second sharing
of common resources isolation is great
but in deployments you certainly have
some resources that you would like to
share across all those clusters and
share VPC enables you to still do that
and have that isolation that you require
third I so listen of data and support
for multi tenant workloads by dividing
your workloads and your teams into
separate projects that you can attach to
your larger project or your
organizational host project you get
isolation of data so it so as to prevent
deliberate or inadvertent attacks that
you might get and for its more granular
billing
we often hear enterprises wanting more
granular billing on a team basis and by
dividing your organization
into those teams and mapping those teams
to projects that work in a shared VPC
model you get more granular Billy let's
look under the hood I think this is too
fuzzy still now so you have your
organization and then you have your host
project your host project consists of
your shared VPC network which consists
of a few subnets and all the critical
network resources that you want to
control then you have your different
apps teams you have your apps project
you have a database infrastructure and
many other things that you might have in
your organization and what you do is you
map all of them to what we call service
projects and you attach all those
service projects to your host project
this way using iam permissions you give
permissions to your project or your team
admins to be able to create and manage
clusters within the boundaries of their
project without affecting any other team
and you enable the network and security
admins to be able to create control the
network the critical network resources
that you don't want the project admins
affecting and so this enables each and
every team to work independently and
with agility moving on to the second
pillar and this comes under runtime
security private deployments private
deployments is a very very crucial
factor for a lot of enterprises a lot of
enterprises want to ensure that their
kubernetes engine deployments are within
the secure boundary of their VPC you
have typically you have a multi multi
tiered application you have a few
front-end apps and you have a lot of
back-end services and your back-end
services which are not exposed to the
internet and don't require public ip's
shouldn't have them and private clusters
enables you to do that private clusters
enables you to cordon off your control
plane and to enable a network
segmentation by removing public IPS from
the nodes and taking your workloads of
the public Internet second of all with
some of the advancement in advancements
in our peering capabilities the
communication between your notes and
Nerys master is completely private and
third using private flusters using
private flusters you can ensure that you
set your control plane to default deny
this way only things that you trust only
the perimeter that you trust has access
to your GK deployments and unauthorized
access whether it's to your nodes or to
your control plane is completely blocked
master authorized networks now with
private clusters you took your notes and
your workloads of the public internet
but you want to be able to manage the
access to your control plane in a more
fine-grained manner you definitely want
to block unauthorized access but there
might be some trusted set of IPS that
you still want to have access to your
kubernetes master so master authorized
networks is the option to set a
whitelist on your control plane to have
access from your trusted set of IPs
which may be only premise or elsewhere
and can control your deployment so
moving on to network security and
drilling down to a clusters the private
deployments ensures that your clusters
are secure network policy works within a
single cluster network security with
network policies ensures that in a in a
model where you have multiple services
within your single cluster they are
secure by being segmented from each
other so let's say you have some
vulnerability which affected the
front-end services we want to ensure
that your front-end services are
compromised but then they don't affect
critical services like billing and
network policies enable you to do that
network policies are user defined
policies that you set on your deployment
which get enforced in real time and
kubernetes engine ensures that your
network policies that the network policy
that you control are enforced in real
time and to the scale that kubernetes
engine supports
now let me sum up all the things that we
that I've mentioned and give you an
overview of how we see security broadly
dividing into config time and run time
where you get separation of
administrative control so that you can
map your organizational topology to your
network is using share VPC with granular
IM rules so that you can ensure that
your project admins create clusters but
do not affect those critical network
resources runtime security consisting of
first of all private deployments which
brad had spoken about earlier private
clusters enables you to take off your
clusters from the public internet and
ensure with master authorize networks
that your control plane is cordoned off
and gives access only to the trusted set
of IPS that you control network security
achieved through network policies which
ensures that in a micro services model
where you have multiple services within
your cluster you control exactly which
services can talk to which other
services instead of the previous way of
having a network level firewall which
gives you an all-or-nothing now moving
on to visibility security is an
important is obviously an important
aspect of all your deployments and
having visibility into what is going on
within your network is equally important
I will show how some of the things that
we are launching at kubernetes engine
help you do that so logging and
monitoring are the cornerstones of your
deployments and kubernetes engine
ensures that you have enough visibility
and flexibility to get information about
your about the traffic flow within your
VPC and VPC flow logs enables you to do
that VPC flow logs captures the traffic
flow whether it's within your V PC
whether it's to and from the internet or
whether it's from your on-premises to
your deployment or if you're using a
host of Google services
so we busy flow logs ensures that it
captures all the traffic flows that are
there within your deployment which you
might want to look into for several
reasons
Reba see flow logs also helps you
optimize your network usage and egress
enabling you to better budget for your
deployments
now we BC flow logs is a raw form of log
that you can use to visualize with a
choice with with your choice of
visualization engine and we have
integration with the host of partners or
you can use tag driver and we busy flow
logs also enables you to get Network
forensics and security analysis to dive
deeper into any attacks that you might
have experienced or within your within
your deployment and lastly it also gives
you a real-time security analysis with a
five second time we busy flow logs is
also flexible in the sense that you can
export that information in a very secure
manner to bigquery or to stock driver
logging as I already mentioned moreover
you might have platforms of platforms
that you prefer to visualize that log
information and you can use cloud
pub/sub to actually export that
information out and visualize it the way
you want this is a typical way in which
you can visualize information from BBC
flow logs where it captures every single
the flows that are there between your
nodes and your pods and you can see here
the overall traffic that is flowing
through your deployment you can see
things like well is it coming from
Central or Europe or which Zone on
region is coming from and you can also
visualize the busiest machines that you
might have now I will call upon Boeing
to give a cool demo of some of the
features that we just spoke about
[Applause]
so hi thanks man Joe in this demo we'll
dig into how a single application spread
across multiple teams and
responsibilities will map to shared VPC
and really see how shared BBC and
private clusters will work in practice
to secure your abs so suppose you have a
multi-tier application that spans
multiple teams in this example you have
an app's team responsible for the
front-end exposing the application
service of the internet you have an
infra team who manages the backend now
for development agility and finer
grained resource accounting you would
like each team to be responsible for
their kubernetes cluster but you have a
net ops team that's responsible for the
overall security and network resource
management so the question is how would
you map this to Google cloud and contain
kubernetes engine so first we start with
the host project the VPC network which
is owned by the net ops team they're
responsible for IP assignments firewall
generally speaking access and resource
allocation and they have full control
over the networking aspects of the host
project next you have the apps team in
their service project and they'll be
managing the front end application also
they will be managing your users coming
in for the internet hitting the
application finally you have the infra
team and now something to notice is that
this effort team also has an additional
requirement they want to keep the nodes
in their kubernetes cluster completely
private but also want to be able to be
accessible from the application so let's
dive in and see what this looks like and
whoops
okay so we have this setup as from
before so let's dive in and see what the
shared V PC setup looks like in your
Google Cloud project so as mentioned
before you have a shared V PC host
project that will be owned by the
network admin in addition you have
attached service projects for each of
the teams so you'll see an attached
service project for the info team an
attached service project for the app
team now let's zoom in on the apps team
and what their application looks like so
for the apps team they're using
kubernetes engine and let's take a look
at our application
it's a pod running on the cluster and
the services is a load balancer service
but first we need to open up the
firewall for the service when you're
running in a shared VPC environment you
can create these services you can expose
them as load balancer which you are
using standard kubernetes primitives but
it's up to the net ops team to actually
expose the firewall so let's do that
okay so this will be done by the net ops
team they will receive a request say hey
I'm creating a service I want to put it
on the Internet and it will be up to the
net ops team to expose the service which
is these two firewalls that then will
expose the kubernetes service to the
Internet users ok so we open the
firewall what next let's zoom in on the
info team so the effort team is managing
a back-end right serving database and
other data now first of all it's a
private cluster so actually you can't
access it directly you know from the
internet as you can with a normal
cluster and you will have to use a
bastion host to access the cluster in
the infra said you have an application
running as a pod and you will also need
to open up a firewall between the apps
and the DB they're part of the same VPC
so they are connectible well
you'll have to do some work to open the
firewall so that these two can
communicate as you see here the net ops
team will be in charge of this and they
will open an apps to back-end firewall
finally let's see these two pieces in
concert so we have the application
front-end on the right side we have the
infrastructure back-end on the left side
and here is our application so our
application is very simple
it says hello next 2018 but as you can
see it comes in from the internet hits
the app the app then queries the backend
inside the VPC in a secure way and then
out the reply goes out back to the user
okay so throughout this presentation
we've seen what it means for kubernetes
engine to be a great platform for
enterprise workloads and I want you to
take away four things from this
presentation first is that kubernetes
engine lets gives you deployment
simplicity so it gives you the tools to
control manage and scale your cluster
resources in a centralized manner and
your clusters will integrate seamlessly
with other GCP resources basically
everything is connected and part of one
VPC and as you could see in the demo you
have multiple teams and they all share
one BBC and you can create applications
that span multiple teams multiple
projects but use the same network second
whoops
second the we get fine-grained control
and shared VPC enables you a separation
of administrative roles set your natural
resources are managed by network ops
without hampering the productivity of
your cut of your other teams in creating
clusters you get security
so with kubernetes engine you can make
every path and surface area secure with
private clusters and master authorized
networks and finally visibility with VPC
flow logs you get views into all of the
flows in your deployment and your VPC
and the one thing I want you to take
away is that all of this is integrated
in a unified experience for all of your
workloads so thank you for coming to our
session and now we will have the Q&A
you
[Music]